so when we sleep and we have an empty
stomach then the activity the
contractile activity of our gut changes
to a very unique pattern it's a
90-minute cycle very powerful waves of
contractions migrate from the esophagus
all the way down to the end of our large
intestine and there they move very
slowly
they've have been so this has been
referred to as the intestinal
housekeeper that sort of cleans the gut
from any residue that's present and the
rhythm for that is generated by the
brain so it's dependent on the input of
the vagus nerve on the on the second
brain and in the gut and this has been
something that also should occur when
during daytime when in between meals
when our stomach and intestinal system
is is empty however with the sort of
modern habit of snacking between meals
so a lot of people don't have that
during the day but have it during sleep
if you add the microbes into this now
it's it's quite likely I'm not really
proving it I mean the microbes obey some
kind of a circadian rhythm by themselves
so they're different during sleep and
during daytime but it's it's quite
plausible to assume that this powerful
wave that sort of cleans everything out
will also affect the microbes the
composition of the microbes because if
we don't have it so people that don't
have that for some for some reason they
will develop abnormal quona sation for
example of their small bowel with a lot
of microbes that don't really belong
there so clearly an important role in
regulating the populations and the
regional distribution of these microbes
now God what happens to in sleeps are
doing during REM sleep and so when we
have
in a lot of activity going on within the
autonomic nervous system circuits within
the brain and the signals are being sent
to the gut so our body is inhibited but
not not our intestinal activity so in in
in many ways emotions that we see
visually that we experience visually in
our dreams have their mirror image in
terms of got activity contractions
secretions and again I mean this like
everything that goes on within our brain
emotionally always is reflected just
like our facial expression reflects our
emotions everything if reflects our
emotional state either during waking
time or sleep time at the gut level and
the microbes will live in that
environment or affected by it so it's
it's an area that's not studied in great
detail but probably very important for
an understanding of how the microbes the
gut and the brain interact and maintain
health so sleep is a very important
ingredient for for health regulation of
the immune system but probably also
regulation of the of gut function and
particularly got microbial integrity and
well-being we know quite a bit about
what happens during sleep and then
during dreaming you know in
psychoanalysis this is a big window into
our emotional life so you know union or
in Freudian psychoanalysis have spent a
lot of time interpreting dreams and
getting an access to this to this
process a big portion is probably the
the processing and consolidation of
memories that have been experienced
during the day many of these of these
memories have a gut feeling component so
because every time we have an emotion
during the day there's always a
counterpart at the gut level that is
then through these sensory pathways goes
back to the brain we may not experience
it during the
a time but it's encoded in this vast
database within the brain so what
happens in during sleep there's this
retrieval and then processing
consolidation of these memories
including all the gut feelings that are
associated with with those experiences
that we had during the day I think it's
a very important point to emphasize that
emotions I have an intricate component
of gut activity and gut feelings
regardless if we feel it like the
butterflies in the stomach or the not in
the stomach every motion has a component
that the brain engages got activity and
that's being reported back to the brain
so you have to look at an emotion really
as a circular process within the brain
gut axis and during sleep and during
dreaming it's there's almost certainly a
consolidation and processing of these
this myriad of gut feelings that are
generated throughout the day